Hi. And welcome to
our fifth enterprise community meetup,
where we'll discuss another end
to end data science workflow
using Posit Team. My
name is Ryan Johnson,
and I'm a data science
advisor here at Posit.
Now for today's session,
we're gonna do things a
little bit differently.
And rather than discuss a single
end to end data science workflow,
we're actually gonna break it
up into a series of smaller
workflows using one of my
favorite packages in both r and
Python called Pins.
Now during today's session,
we'll start off with a
brief introduction into Posit Team,
and then we'll talk about
how Posit Team, specifically Posit
Connect can be used to
enhance your pin's workflows.
So with that,
let's go ahead and get started
with an introduction to Posit Team.
Alright. If you joined
us in the past months,
then you probably seen
this diagram before.
This is a quick
overview of Posit Team.
And we'll start right up here
at the very top with your data
scientists, your data
analysts, your end users.
And they will be creating
insights using Posit Workbench.
This is a development
environment,
and they can develop
within RStudio, Jupyter, or
VSCode, creating things
in both R and Python.
So for your R developers,
maybe they're creating shiny
applications, quarto documents, plumber APIs,
or if you have
Python developers,
maybe they're creating
applications using things like
Bokeh or Dash, streamlit.
You can have Jupyter notebooks
as well, shiny for Python,
pins for Python, which we'll
talk about in a bit here.
But it doesn't do the
data scientists any good if they
can't share that content with the
people that need to see it.
That could be their coworkers,
it could be their boss,
or maybe just their
friends and family,
and that's where Posit
Connect comes into play.
Connect is our professional
publishing platform and allows
you to easily share those
insights with whoever you want.
And then finally, we have
Posit Package Manager,
which does exactly
as this name implies,
help control all those great open
source packages in both r and Python.
And you can also host and
share any internally developed r and
Python packages with
your team as well.
Now for today's workflow, we're gonna
focus on pins. And in a second,
I'll explain what the pins
package is and how you use it,
but I thought it might be
helpful to first describe a few
scenarios where you might want
to consider using the pins
package for your workflows.
In this first scenario, Have
you ever created an asset,
maybe like a piece of data
that you thought was the final
version of the data,
but then you had to go back
and make some edits and create
another final version.
And rather than overwriting
the original dataset,
you decide to give
it a new name.
And maybe you go through this
process again and again and again,
and you end up with multiple
final versions of a data set.
And no one knows what the
true final version is.
Maybe this data we just talked
about is used by many different
content types, including a shiny
app in r, or a quarto
document in Python,
and you're worried that the
data may not be consistent
across all assets.
Additionally,
maybe you want to share
this data with multiple people,
and it's typically much easier
and safer to share a pin
rather than trying to
email files around.
And finally, maybe this
data contains sensitive information,
and you only want to share
it with specific people or groups
of people. And this is actually
possible when using pins in
combination with Posit Connect.
So how do pins actually work?
The best way to think of pins
in my opinion is to think of a
cork board similar to how you can
pin a note to a cork board,
you can pin an R or Python
object to a board where
you and others can access it.
To further explain this
cork board analogy,
the push pin is the tool we
use to pin an object to the cork
board. This is
the pins package.
The note that we pin is our
R or Python object, and this
could be a data set, a
model, plots, or even files.
Finally,
the cork board in our workflows
for today will be Posit
Connect. Now there are a lot
of other boards you could use,
including Amazon S3, Azure,
or Google Cloud Storage, or
even local or shared folders.
But Posit Connect does come
with some added advantages,
which we'll discuss today.
Before we get
started with pins,
we need to do a small
amount of prep work.
And since we are going to show
some workflows in both R and Python,
we'll first need to install
the pins package in both languages,
and then we'll need to
connect to our board,
which again will be Posit
Connect. So let's do that now,
and we'll start
with r in RStudio.
So here I am within
Posit workbench,
and the first thing I'm
going to do is log in.
Now that we're within
Posit Workbench,
the first thing I'm going to do is
click on a new session and select rstudio
The
easiest way to connect to
Posit connect from within the
rstudio IDE is to go to
tools at the top of your
screen and select
global options,
On the left hand side,
there will be a publishing option,
and we'll want to
select connect.
In the pop up menu, we want
to select Posit connect,
And here is where you want
to add the URL for your connect
server where you can see mine
is already pre populated.
So I'll click next. We'll
get another pop up window.
This is asking if we want
to confirm the connection.
I'll hit connect. Gonna add
my password one more time here,
and then we can click log in.
I'll close out of this window,
and hit connect account.
I'll apply these changes
and then hit okay.
So coming back to my slides
here, this is gonna be the
first workflow that we're
gonna discuss today.
I'm going to take an object
that we build in r and show you
how to pin it to Posit Connect.
Alright. So coming back to
my rstudio session within Posit Workbench,
The first thing we need to do
in order to pin an object to
Posit connect is first install
and load the pins package.
So coming over to my console,
I'm going to first install
pins.
I'm gonna hit enter, and I want
you to know how fast it goes.
It's already done, and
that's because I pulled in a
pre-built binary,
a Linux binary from my instance
of Posit package manager.
That's one of the advantages
of using package manager as well.
And once we've installed
it, I can go ahead and
type out library and we're
gonna load the pins package.
You know, clear my screen,
and we're good to go.
And next, we need to
define our pins board.
So we're gonna create a
new variable. I'm gonna call it
my_board.
And we're gonna
assign this variable.
We're gonna give it a
function from within the pins package.
So within pins, there
is a function called
board_connect,
and that's it. That's the only thing
we need to run. I'll hit enter.
And you can see it's
successfully connected to Posit Connect.
Now we need something
to pin to Posit Connect.
So to keep it nice and simple,
we're gonna use a
dataset within R called
mtcars. And if I hit enter, you
can see what that dataset looks like.
So we're gonna take this
dataset and we're going to pin
it to Posit Connect.
To do that, we are going to
use from within the pins package, the
pin_write function.
We then need to give it the
name of my board, so my board.
Then we need to give it
the pin, the r object,
so that's the empty
car's data set.
And then we want to give this
pin a name. And so I'm gonna
call it my username in this
instance, which is Posit. I'll say
mtcars_R since this is an
r object. I'll hit enter,
and now you can see it
successfully wrote the pin as Posit
mtcars_R
So let's go ahead and navigate
to our instance of Posit Connect.
And there's our pin
right at the top.
I'll go ahead and
click on the pin,
And this is what it looks
like, hosted on Posit Connect.
I could click that link right
there at the top to download
the raw RDS file,
And right below that is all
the code you would need to read
that pin into your
various workflows.
And we'll talk about
that here in a second.
And then at the very bottom,
you can actually get a snippet
of what the data looks like.
Now, before I show you
that exact same workflow in Python,
I first wanna talk a little
bit about what you're seeing over
here on the right hand side
of your screen within Posit
Connect. And these are
your access controls.
So you can determine how you
want this pin, this dataset to
be shared across
your team. Currently,
I have it set to specific
users or groups and you can define
those users and groups right
here in the search box,
which will be tied to
your authentication.
Now if you want to be
a little less strict,
I can select all
users login required,
that means if you can log
in to this instance of Posit Connect,
you can view this
pinned dataset.
Or I can select anyone
no login required,
and that will open up this pin
data set to the world so that
anyone could access it.
Alright. So if I come
back to my slides,
for our second workflow, I'm gonna
show you how to pin a
Python object to Posit Connect.
Now coming back to our
Posit Workbench homepage,
I'm gonna open up a new session
alongside our our studio
session. So I'll select
new session. And this time,
I'm going to select JupyterLab,
and we'll hit start session.
And here I have a
terminal session opened up already,
and we're first going
to install the pins package.
So to do that for Python,
we're gonna use pip to
install pins and hit enter.
And you can see the
requirements already satisfied,
so we should be good to
go. I'll clear my screen.
Next, I'm gonna open
up a Jupyter Notebook.
So I'll click on this blue icon
over here and select a new notebook.
Now the first thing we
want to do is to import
the pins package that
we just installed.
And we also need similar
to our R workflow,
we need something to pin.
And we're actually gonna pin
the same dataset, but again,
we're doing this within Python.
So from
pins.data, we're
going to import the
mtcars data set,
and I'll go ahead and run this.
And to pin this empty
car's data set to Posit Connect,
we first need to register our
board just like we did before.
So our board, I'll
call it my_board again.
And this is going to be created
using from within the pins
package the
board_connect function.
And we're gonna run this,
but before we do that,
we need two things. We first
need to define our server URL,
and we also need to provide
this function an API key so
that this Jupyter
notebook knows who I am.
So the first thing we're
gonna add is the URL.
So I'm gonna come back to Posit
Connect. I'm gonna grab the
URL, So you probably can't see
this on your screen. That's okay.
So copy this.
And I'm gonna add the URL.
And the next thing we need
to add is the API key.
To generate an API key in Posit
connect, we're gonna go back to connect,
and I'm gonna click my name
here in the top right hand
corner and select API key.
Now as a quick caveat here,
I am using a temporary
environment, and as soon
as this demo's over,
it's gonna be torn down. So you
will see my API key, but that's
okay. For future reference,
you should always treat your API
key just like you would a password.
You wanna keep them safe
and not share them with anybody.
So to generate an API key
in Posit Connect, I'll select new
API key, I'll call
this workbench
API key and hit okay.
I'm gonna copy this
come back to our
Python notebook,
and paste it in there. And
then we'll run this command.
And so the last thing we need
to do is pin our mtcars data
set to Posit Connect.
So to start, we are going
to type out my_board,
and we're gonna use
the pin.write function.
Now for this for within Python,
it takes three arguments,
and the first argument
is the pin itself.
So we're gonna use mtcars.
The next is the name, and
we're gonna give this a similar name.
So I'll say my
username, which is Posit
And I'm gonna call it
mtcars_Python, because if you
recall, the other name was
mtcars_R since that
was an R
And the last thing we need
to give it in this environment
here is the type. So how
do you wanna save this?
We're gonna save
it as a CSV file.
And that's it. We'll
run this command.
And now you can see that
has written this pin to Posit Connect.
And if we come back to Posit
Connect, you see on your
screen, and I click content,
Now we can see our two
pins. Here's our mtcars pin that we
created in r, and then here's
the mtcars pin we created in Python.
So now that we have both
objects, now pinned to Posit Connect,
I'm now gonna show you how
to read pins And we're gonna start
here with reading a pin into
an r session. And to make things
interesting, we're actually going
to read in the Python
object into our r session,
and then vice versa.
Alright. So reading a pin is
super easy. We are going to
use from within
the pins package,
the pin_read function.
We'll next give it our
board, which again we call my_board,
and now the name of the pin.
And so I want to read
in the Python pin, which we called
posit/mtcars_Python.
And that's pretty much
it. We'll hit enter.
And that's how you can read
in the Python mtcars data set
into an r session.
So let's go ahead and
do the same thing,
but this time in Python.
So we're gonna read in our
r object and Posit connect into
our Python session.
Alright. So now we're back
in our Jupyter Lab session.
And to read in a pin in
Python, we're gonna again start with my
board. And reuse the
pin_read function.
And the only thing you need to
give it is the name of the pin.
And so if you recall,
we saved it as Posit/mtcars_R
It's gonna use your name,
empty cars, and I wanna
read in this r object.
Now I'm actually expecting
an error message.
So let me run this.
Yep. And so we do
get an error message.
And if we look towards the
bottom here. No driver for type
rds. So when we save
the r object to Posit connect,
by default, it uses an rds
format, and that's actually not
compatible with Python.
So we need to change that.
Let me come back to
my RStudio session.
And we're going to rewrite that
pin. So from the pins package,
we use pin_write
will give it the
name of my board,
the object we want to
pin, which is mtcars,
the name, which, again,
keep the name the same,
Posit/mtcars_R And this
time, we're gonna add a type
argument, and we're going
to save it as a CSV file.
Hit enter, and there we go.
So now let's come back to
our Jupyter notebook, and let's try
re running this command.
And there we go. There's
our r object read into a
Python session.
So for all of our
subsequent workflows,
I'm going to show them in R
and RStudio just for the sake of time.
But everything I show can
also be implemented in Python too.
So for our next
workflow, workflow five,
I'm going to introduce
you to pin versioning.
Now it may come as a
surprise that we actually already did
this when we rewrote our
r pin as a CSV file. We
didn't delete the original.
We actually just created a new
version on top of the original.
So in this workflow,
I'll show you how you can
see the various versions of your
pin and how you can easily
switch between them.
So now if I come back to
Posit Connect, here you can see the r
object that we pinned.
So if I click into it,
you can see the most recent version
is the CSV format that we saved.
Now Posit Connect also allows
you to view the previous
versions as well. So if I
click on the three dots,
you see here in the top
left corner, I can select history.
And we have two
current versions.
So here's the most
recent version.
I can click on a previous
version and see there's the rds
format that we
saved previously.
Now just for fun,
let's go ahead and create a
third version of this pin. So
I'm gonna just extract the
first row of the mtcars data
set. We'll save that
as a new variable,
and then we'll pin that to
the same exact location, the same pin.
So I'm gonna create a new data set,
the mtcars data set where
I'm just gonna extract the first
row. So that's what the
new pin is gonna look like.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and save that as mtcars2
and create a new variable.
And now let's go ahead and
save it as a pin to the same
location. So from within
the pins package, pin_write,
give it the name of my board,
the new object,
so that's mtcars2.
The name of the pin. So
we wanna save it to the same
location. So let's
do Posit/mtcars_R and
we'll make the type again
a CSV format and hit enter.
And now we've pinned a third
version of this dataset.
And if we come back to Posit
Connect, I'll click into my R pin.
Select history.
And now you can see I
have three versions of the pinned
dataset. So this is
the most recent pin,
which will be the
the active pin,
and then we can see the
historical versions as well.
And you can also view the
previous versions from within
your r session. So there
is a function within pins
called pin_versions.
We'll give it again my board,
and then the name
of the pin. So
thats posit/mtcars_R and
hit enter. And so you can
see we have three versions
of the same pin, and the most
recent version that we pin is
going to be the active version.
So if we ever read in the pin,
this is gonna be the
one that it reads in.
But let's say you wanna go
back to a previous version.
You can see that each version
has a unique number and unique
identifier to it. So if
I want to read in Maybe
we'll just read in the most
recent version to start.
So I'll do pin_read.
Again, I'll give it my board,
and the name of
the pin.
So that's the most
recent version,
but if I run the same
command, but this time,
I'm gonna add in
another argument called version,
and I'm gonna give it this
previous version right here. So
20, hit enter,
And that's how you can read
in a previous version of your pin.
For our last
workflow for today,
we are going to show you how
you can automate the pin writing process.
This is probably the workflow
I use the most often,
and it's perfect for
those assets that are constantly
changing or being updated.
Think of a data set where new rows
are being added as data is being collected.
So this specific pin's workflow
is made possible by the job
scheduling feature on Posit
Connect. So to get started,
we first need to create a
document that houses our pin
writing workflow. So let me
navigate back to Posit Workbench.
Alright. So now that I'm
back within this RStudio session,
within Posit Workbench,
the first thing I'm going
to do is open up a new,
and we'll select Quarto,
for this workflow. And if
you're not familiar with Quarto,
we actually have a previous
end to end workflow session where
we really focused it on Quarto.
So on the top left corner,
I'm going to select quarto document,
and I'm gonna call this
"My Pins
Workflow",
and we'll hit create.
So here is a new
quarto document,
and it has some
placeholder text in here,
which I'm just gonna
delete for right now.
So let's go ahead and
script this pins writing workflow.
The first thing I want to do
is load the pins package. So I'm
gonna insert a new R cell,
and we're going to load the
pins package, and we'll run that.
After that, I'm going
to read and transform
my raw data. Now, we're gonna
stick with the mtcars data set,
but I'm going to extract
a few additional rows.
So think of this as pulling
in some raw data set and doing
some type of transformation
to clean it up,
which we'll eventually
write as a pin.
So we'll insert
a new cell here.
And the first thing I'm going
to do is create a new variable.
I'll call it mtcars3.
And we are going to make
that or assign that to the
mtcars data set, and I'm just
going to extract the first five rows.
And then we can print it here,
and we can run this code cell.
And so that's what this
new pin is gonna look like.
So this is what we're going to
read or sorry, write to Posit Connect.
So the last thing we want to
do is the actual pin writing
process. So we want to pin to
Posit Connect.
Now since it's going to
be hosted within Posit Connect,
we still need to make that
board connection. So I'm going to
write out my_board and this
is gonna be board_connect. That's
the the pins function
you wanna use here.
And then let's go ahead
and write out the actual
pin_write function.
So we assign it,
provide it with my board,
the new mtcars3
data set. And let's go ahead
and give this a new name.
So I'll say, posit/mtcars3,
and we'll just keep it simple,
and call it mtcars3.
And let's go ahead and
save it as a CSV file.
Now let's go ahead and run
all this and just make sure
everything works
as expected. First,
I'm gonna actually save it.
So I'll call this pins_workflow,
and hit save.
And now you can see it
down here in my file directory.
So let's go ahead
and run all these
code cells, then just make
sure everything works well.
And it looks good.
You can see that it's
successfully pinned it to Posit Connect.
Now, again, I want you
to think of this dataset.
Maybe it changes every single
day or every single week,
and you wanna set up this
workflow to run automatically.
To do that,
the first thing we need to
do is publish it to Posit Connect.
So the easiest way to
publish this quarto document to Posit
Connect is to go into this
little blue button you see at
the top of your
screen and select publish document.
So it's gonna ask for few
additional packages that need
to be installed. And again,
this will go nice and quick
since we're using Posit package manager.
We wanna select Posit Connect,
and we wanna make sure
we publish document with the
source code because that's
gonna allow us to rerun it on
the connect server.
So this is the only
file we need to pin.
This is the location
of our connect server,
which you can see we
already registered,
very early on in this workflow,
and we'll just leave the
title as Pins_workflow.
And I'll go ahead and
hit publish, and that's it.
And you're gonna see this
deploy tab that opens up.
I'm just gonna print
some logs to the screen.
And we'll just give this a
few seconds to publish to Posit Connect.
And there we go. Here is
the Quarto document we just
created now hosted
on Posit Connect.
So to set this up
for job scheduling, you'll want to
click the schedule tab,
which can be accessed by
clicking this gear icon on the
top of your screen. So
I'll click schedule,
We'll select this box.
You can choose your time zone
and the start date and time for
this recurring job.
Next, you can choose
the frequency. So by default,
you can see it's set up to
run every single day at 11 AM.
But you can change this,
you can make it as frequent
as the minute or every two minutes,
or you can make it as
infrequent as every year or
every two years if
you really wanted to.
But I think daily sounds good.
And we'll have that
run every single day.
You can also choose
every single weekday.
And then once we are finished,
it's going to rerun this
report and publish it,
and you also have the
option to send an email.
So if you wanna let someone
on your team know that this Quarto
document was rerun,
they can get an email
directly in their inbox.
And so once we save this,
now every single day at 11
AM, it is going to rewrite this
mtcars3 data set to that pin
on Posit Connect. So it's a great
way to keep those pins updated
on a recurring schedule that you choose.
And with that, we've come to
the end of our session today.
Now I hope you found
this content helpful,
and you can feel a
bit more confident about implementing
pins into your own workflow.
Thanks again, everyone,
for joining today.
And feel free to stick around
if you have any questions you'd
like to ask us. Otherwise,
have a great rest of your day,
and we hope see you
again next month.
Thanks so much, Ryan.
Pins is something that had
come up quite a bit in the data
science hangouts lately,
so it's awesome to have these
pins workflows to point to as
well. As Ryan mentioned,
we are going stick around here
for some q and a for another
fifteen minutes or so,
and YouTube should
automatically push you over to
that. If for any
reason it doesn't,
I've also included the
link in the details below,
and I'm gonna copy that over
to the chat right now too.
As a reminder,
there's also a slide open
for anonymous questions,
which you can see on the
screen, but that's at
pos.it/demo-questions,
and we'll keep that open for
the rest of the week as well,
and I'll add the
answers in there too.
Thanks again for
joining us today,
and we'll see you over
there for Q and A.